nuestra meta es simplificar esta
expresión para el error cuadrática de
los n puntos recordemos que estábamos
haciendo acá arriba teníamos n puntos y
estamos haciendo la suma de los errores
al cuadrado de cada uno de los puntos
hacia la línea tal vez debería llamarle
la recta pero vamos a dejarlo en línea
de ahí obtuvimos esta expresión verdad
ahorita ya más o menos la empezamos a
trabajar pero lo que queremos hacer
ahorita es simplificar la lo más posible
para poder optimizar la queremos
encontrar un mínimo para el error
cuadrática de la línea entonces queremos
dar una m y una vez que minimicen esta
expresión de aquí para hacer eso pues
parece ser que ahorita pues se está
poniendo más y más espeluznante el
álgebra pero este siguiente paso va a
simplificar mucho las cosas para
mostrarte lo vamos a pensar en el
promedio de el promedio de las jie
cuadradas con promedio me refiero a
media aritmética vale nos quedaría 1 al
cuadrado más
de 2 al cuadrado más y así sucesivamente
hasta que llegamos a g n al cuadrado ahí
tenemos la suma de n valores entonces
hay que dividir entre la cantidad que es
n esto de aquí lo vamos a denotar de la
siguiente forma vamos a ponerle ya al
cuadrado promedio va el gorrito quiere
decir el promedio y aquí abajo vamos a
ponerle cuadrado este es el promedio de
las jie cuadradas ahora si multiplicamos
a ambos lados de la ecuación por n
obtenemos lo siguiente lleva 1 al
cuadrado más de 2 al cuadrado más y así
sucesivamente hasta que llegamos a más n
al cuadrado es igual a n veces estamos
multiplicando por n déjame ponerlo con
color amarillo lo voy a poner así
entonces es igual a n multiplicado por
el promedio de las jie cuadradas ya
cuadrada promedio
observa que esto de aquí este primer
término de nuestra suma es exactamente n
veces el promedio de las ye cuadradas
vale muy bien entonces esto de aquí es
la idea para simplificar un poquito la
expresión ahorita vamos a seguir
haciendo esto para cada uno de los
términos pasemos al segundo sumando a
equis uno y uno más
x 2 de 2 + tatata y así hasta más x n&n
bueno si tenemos toda esta suma y la
dividimos entre n porque son n términos
nos quedaría el promedio de los x y así
lo vamos a denotar como x barrita osea
sumamos con todos los subíndices y luego
dividimos entre n una vez más si
multiplicamos por n ambos lados
obtenemos lo siguiente x 1 y 1 más x 2 2
más y así sucesivamente tatata mas x nn
es igual a
es igual a otra vez en amarillo n veces
el promedio de las equis y es entonces n
por xy promedio va vamos a seguir
haciendo esto sin hacer las cuentas tan
explícitamente acá arriba le voy a poner
que este término de acá es n por el
promedio de las equis y de modo similar
en el tercer término nos queda n veces
el promedio de los valores de las yes
eso es este término de aquí luego
pasando acá abajo tenemos n veces el
promedio de las x es cuadradas a lo
mejor suena mejor si digo el promedio de
los valores de las x es cuadradas bueno
como sea luego por acá tenemos el
promedio de las x es x n porque pues si
estuviera dividido entre n sería el
promedio pero como no lo está es n veces
el promedio finalmente hay un n b
cuadrada que vamos a dejar así bueno
vamos a reescribir todo para estrenar
nuestra nueva anotación en términos de
promedios después las íes cuadradas y
los productos y así entonces nos queda
que el error cuadra
de la línea es el error cuadra tico de
ciertos puntos a la línea
mx ve es igual a este primer sumando
déjame usar colores distintos
no voy a poner así en morado es n x el
promedio de las jie cuadradas muy bien
luego el segundo término que voy a
pintar así en verde deja pongo todo en
verde
es menos dos veces m es esto de ahí x n
multiplicado por el promedio de los
productos xy muy bien vamos al tercer
término y creo que ahorita ya vas a ver
que esto se simplifica un poco más va a
estar en términos de promedios pero esos
van a ser constantes es menos dos veces
p x
n veces n veces el promedio de los
valores de jacques allá arriba no le
había puesto promedio bueno no le hace
luego tenemos más que este término de
acá más m cuadrada m cuadrada por n
multiplicado por el promedio de los
valores de los x cuadrada de las x
cuadrada
y luego ya casi acabamos es el último
jalón es más dos veces
mb x n multiplicado por el promedio de
los valores de x y finalmente tenemos
que sumar n veces b cuadrada + n veces b
cuadrada muy bien en los últimos dos o
tres vídeos lo único que hemos hecho es
plantear el error cuadrática y
simplificar pues de alguna forma este
error va otra vez este error total viene
de la suma de los errores verticales de
los puntos a la línea pero esos errores
elevados al cuadrado esto de aquí
termina con la parte intensiva de
álgebra en la siguiente etapa lo que
queremos hacer es optimizar esta
expresión que quiero decir con optimizar
esta expresión lo que queremos hacer es
encontrar los valores de m y de b que
minimizan esta expresión que ya acabamos
de encontrar es decir pues vamos a hacer
un poco de derivadas parciales y así
pero bueno antes de pasar a cuentas de
cálculo vamos a visualizar el error
cuadrática en tres dimensiones
vamos a hacer pues este error cuadra
tico es una función de dos variables es
una función de m dv de esta forma
determinar una superficie en el espacio
son sólo dos variables porque todo lo
que no es ni m ni ves son constantes en
efecto observa que todo lo demás como
los puntos ya están dados pues es un
numerito tenemos promedios de x es
cuadradas y así pero son puros numeritos
todas las x es y las yes vienen de
puntos que ya nos dan sí entonces todos
los promedios ya son ciertos números ok
déjame dibujar lo voy a poner por aquí
el eje el egm va luego del otro lado a
este de acá le voy a poner el eje y por
acá sigue el eje m
los valores negativos los valores
negativos del egb y finalmente podemos
imaginar el eje vertical algo de este
estilo verdad como el eje del error
cuadra tico de la línea el error
cuadrática de la línea entonces para
cualquier combinación de m y de b en el
plano m pues lo que hacemos es poner la
arriba eso nos da un cierto error
eso nos da un punto en z bueno en el
error cuadrática si hiciéramos todas las
posibles combinaciones de mv pues ya
hemos visto que esto nos determina una
superficie ahí en el espacio se va a ver
más o menos algo de este estilo deja de
intentar dibujarla es algo que se parece
un poquito a una parábola por así
decirlo ahorita no me está quedando muy
bien imagínate la más bien como en 3d va
entonces es más o menos como un tazón o
como un calcetín o algo por el estilo
déjame intentar hacer una analogía o sea
acá en el plano tenemos una parábola y
aquí sí está la rotar amos alrededor de
su eje entonces obtendremos un
paraboloide algo como la punta de un
calcetín en fin lo que queremos hacer es
encontrar los valores bmv que nos den
este punto mínimo es decir el punto que
quede más abajo en el eje del error
cuadrática déjame pintar un poquito más
de la superficie algo de este estilo
voy a dibujar por acá la parte de atrás
que es lo que no vemos hay que dar la
parte de adentro del calcetín
ahora lo que queremos encontrar en los
valores de m y de b que hagan mínimo el
valor de pues de esta superficie o sea
que nos deje la mínima altura en el
error cuadrática para hacer esto es
decir para hacer la parte de cálculo lo
que vamos a hacer es encontrar derivadas
parciales primero la parcial del error
cuadrática con respecto a m y luego la
parcial de esta expresión con respecto a
b después de eso vamos a igualar
ambas parciales a 0 porque pues es la
misma idea de siempre en los puntos
críticos las funciones tienen derivada
igual a cero de este modo aquí déjame
marcarlo en este punto crítico la
pendiente tanto con respecto a b como
con respecto a m va a ser igual a 0 es
decir en este punto la parcial del error
cuadrática con respecto a m es igual a 0
y de modo similar y la parcial del error
cuadrática con respecto a b también va a
ser igual a 0 excelente lo que haremos
en el siguiente vídeo será uno encontrar
las parciales del error cuadrática con
respecto a m b y dos igualadas a cero
encontrar un sistema de ecuaciones a
partir del cual podamos concluir en el
vídeo final resolveremos el sistema y
sacaremos todo del horno